هذه صوره لتضرر احد الجسور فيها طاي تبقى
معنا اذا هذه صور نشاهدها مباشره الانفصال
جسر عن طريق رئيسي فيها طاي بتركيا جراء
الزلزال الجديد
ونسمع بوضوح سيارات
الشرطه والاسعاف
تهرع في هذا الوقت الى هذه الامكنه التي
تضررت مع انتشار المروحيات الى المراقبه
الجويه كما افادم زيدان قبل خليل في هاتاي
كما درج عليه الحال في الايام الاولى
للزلزال الكبير في السادس من فبراير اذن
يعني هذه المعطيات الاوليه الصور الاوليه
الفيديوهات الاوليه التي تريدنا لمختلف
المناطق
المتضرره كان زيدان نقل لنا ايضا وجود
حواجز للشرطه التركيه التي تمنع استخدام
الانفاق كاجراءات احترازيه ليس لكل اجراء
ان يعني ان هناك ما وراءه او اسباب يعني
تحود دون ذلك مما يمكن ان يحصل في الساعات
المقبله ولكن كاجراءات احترازيه احيانا
هناك مباني بطبيعه الحال تتصدع تتضرر
وبالتالي السلطات تتخذ كل اجراءاتها
اللازمه لمنع سقوط قتلى وجرحى بسبب ما حصل
اذا هذه اخر الصور التي نشاهدها سياره
الاسعاف تمر من هذا الطريق اذا ونشاهد صور
انفصال الجسر اذا عن هذا الطريق